we are joined now by CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus David good
morning health experts were forecasting
and anticipating this as the country
reopened what do we do to keep those
numbers down and should some places
reconsider reopening further you know
it's gonna be hard to reconsider opening
I think we've been indoors for a long
time but we need to change our way of
life I mean if there's one thing we
could all do that would decrease the
spread of this it's to wear a mask we
have to create a new social norm which
is wearing the mask you know countries
like Japan it's no big deal because they
were used to wearing a mask here this is
a big deal and we're asking the least
affected the 20 the 30 40 40 year olds
to step up to help others and that's new
for our country David there's been a lot
of concern that the widespread protest
could contribute to a spike what do we
know about that is there any evidence
that's happening yeah I think we're
gonna I mean we're seeing little bits of
it now we're gonna see more of it over
the days to come and you know many of
the rallies were these twenty and thirty
year olds they're gonna go home and
they're gonna bring it to the people in
their household you know mother and
grandma and father and grandfather and
next-door neighbor and that's what we
worry about
I don't worry about the 20 and 30 year
olds because they're not gonna get very
sick in general are they clear
exceptions but they can spread it to
others who are more vulnerable and that
spike in hospitalizations is going to
continue to rise over the next several
days as a result of the protests and
it's not just in the big cities remember
people went from small towns to
participate in larger towns and then
they went back to their hometown and
we're gonna see spread in smaller towns
there weren't spread before so should
they quarantine after being in a protest
David I don't think they should
quarantine I think it's a little
aggressive at this point to do that but
I do think they should all wear a mask
they need to block the spread of
droplets from one person to another we
have a new way of life these next months
until a vaccine comes you know everybody
knew what to do during the lockdown that
first inning we were good at it but the
second is inning is
Fuzzy's and we need to behave
differently and wearing a mass is
different it's not in our DNA to focus
on others but we need to you mentioned
the vaccine David what what's the latest
on developments in vaccine
well I'm smiling III think that the data
so far in the leaf candidates is very
encouraging and so I really think
there's a possibility that an early fall
we will have vaccine candidates for
healthcare workers for the highest risk
individuals and then more as the supply
increases but the data is so far like
encouraging and there haven't been any
backward steps and that's exciting no
that's very good news all right dr.
David agus thank you David